now this is a contradiction but it's
another one in Tai Chi it's called the
bird's beak where you put all your
fingers together and the thumb goes the
thumb goes in the middle
the bird's beak goes over
and it's the same as the Open Hand
so this is as long as you're all right
with contradictions you get on well in
Nike though all right because this I'm
saying the complete opposite and I about
the fingers
but you don't know what situation you're
in what about if he's holding my fingers
you know how am I gonna oh I can
just something you've got to about to
adapt to any
position
it comes up
it goes over
and I'm going to go through all these
other pieces
he's on forgotten your name cool
goal there you go okay
if I say okay it's just backwards yeah
no okay
so
he's on the line his arm's on the line
and this is what's happening those who
can see it you're sort of turning over
and it's going this side the line and
then by the time you get there it's gone
that side of the line
and you you know you third downs and
above really should be
keeping it exactly
on the line and you should be moving you
should be moving
so birds beat over out all right so this
now isn't that isn't that
so so don't get confused by going here
here oh I need to open my fingers
because it you know it's not going to be
right is it
strong
yeah
that's when you open your fingers
when you when you're going to let your
full tiger out of the
hey
can't get out it's because I again hey
still on the line
all right the more they hold the more
you'll find that it will vary where it's
going keep it where it is
and you'll get it okay so the bird's
beak
it goes over under
and out
okay done